console gaming and cars have always been
kind of incompatible
but now automakers are changing that see
as they invest heavily in software and
over-the-air updates to their vehicles
in-car entertainment is also being
leveled up and that's creating a new
source of revenue for car manufacturers
and software developers so what's on
offer today and what's coming down the
road let's find out
[Music]
okay so while in-car gaming might seem
like fun and games quite literally for
automakers it's set to be big business
McKinsey research suggests that in-car
entertainment could generate between 30
to 60 billion dollars in value by 2030
and as many automakers push towards an
autonomous future it follows that they
should also bolster their entertainment
offerings for a future when drivers
might not have to pay attention to the
road so what's available well let's
start with the dashboard and CES 2023
Nvidia announced that its GeForce now
cloud gaming platform which includes
over a thousand gaming titles would soon
be available in cars that use its Nvidia
Drive ecosystem that's Polestar byd and
Hyundai the games are only accessible
from the front when the car is
stationary but players in the back can
game on the go then there's BMW's
partnership with n dream which was
announced last year and dreams gaming
platform called air console is accessed
through the dashboard and controlled
using smartphones if you think this
looks fun wait till you see what else
BMW has planned more on that later now
if you're a Tesla owner watching this
you're probably wondering what all the
fuss is about after all some Tesla
owners have been able to stream content
and play games in their cars for years
at one point even while driving which
got them into some hot water but the
company recently dramatically expanded
its gaming offering by adding the steam
gaming platform to the latest model S
and X Vehicles which means you can play
thousands of the latest games as long as
you're parked
but what if you wanted a more immersive
experience that completely takes you
away from a boring Journey while
somebody else handles the driving enter
holleride the startup has developed an
in-car VR Gaming experience featuring a
headset which and this is the clever
part syncs up with the movement of your
vehicle so if the car turns left so does
your in-game character and this resolves
this conflict in the inner ear and you
don't get motion sick as easily as you
do otherwise until recently this Tech
was only available in certain Audis but
at CES 2023 hollaride unveiled a
retrofit kit that allows you to install
it into any vehicle Uber drivers I'm
looking at you
all of that Tech is set to be available
this year but what about the future well
automakers are betting that augmented
reality is going to play a big part in
the future of in-car entertainment at
CES 2023 BMW showcased this it's iVision
D concept which features a slider where
you can essentially dial in how much
reality you want to see this is where
you open the portal to the virtual world
Board of your surroundings World getting
a little bit too bland turn the slider
all the way up and experience a surreal
New World while hopefully not hitting
anyone I'm really hoping that car was
supposed to be driverless the company
also pointed to a future where social
feeds are pumped directly into the
vehicle and the car itself has a
personality much like kit from Knight
Rider do you wish further information on
Silicon Valley hell no I want to know
who you are and how you're listening in
now as with many things CES it's unclear
how much of that fever dream is set to
become a reality though BMW have said
that an Advan Advanced heads-up display
is coming to its cars in 2025 but BMW is
far from the only automaker to mention
augmented reality in their future plans
and that same CES Sony and Honda's new
afila EV and vw's id7 all mention the
technology and at its software day in
2022 stellantis pointed to its DS and
Jeep Brands all featuring augmented
reality screens in the future for now
though that remains a distant reality so
if you're going on a long boring drive
anytime soon I'd recommend loading up on
some good podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]